I support her yeah yeah so you know
whatever whatever she wants uh the
maurys have her back
um I love her dearly Tamara Mori Housley
speaks out following news that her twin
sister Tia Mori is getting a divorce
they have this expectation going into
marriage that everything is going to be
perfect nothing is perfect on Tuesday
Tia announced that she filed for divorce
from her husband Corey Hardrick after 14
years of marriage posting this pic on
Instagram and writing in part quote
these decisions are never easy and not
without sadness adding that they will
maintain a friendship as they co-parent
the two children they share
eleven-year-old son cree and
four-year-old daughter Cairo family is
so important to me quote I am grateful
for all the happy times we had together
and want to thank my friends family and
fans for your love and support as we
start this new chapter moving forward in
our lives her twin sister offered her
support in the comments writing love you
and on Wednesday morning Tamara stopped
by today with Hoda and Jenna and shared
how the family is rallying around Tia
she is strong but I know right now she
just kind of just wants to
you know just kind of just process it
all take it all in and you know be a
little private about that and you know
as a sister you know yeah I'm just gonna
respect that
ET was with Tia just last week the actor
is still on cloud nine from her Italian
getaway with Corey and their kids in
July to be in Italy with again with our
children and our husbands it was just so
amazing and surreal surreal and just so
wonderful at the time Tia shared clips
from their getaway alongside the caption
I love traveling the world with you just
walking down the streets and just having
a great time and drinking our Spritz
just sharing Stories the two met in the
early 2000s
I was waiting on the bus stop I was at
my first film her sister and I drove by
they saw me waiting they asked me to
give me a ride I was just like
embarrassed I was downtown yeah gave me
a ride and we were friends ever since
fast forward to April 2008. and they
tied the knot in Santa Barbara
Cory is really chill and he's very like
laid back and he's really cool but on
his wedding day
I I still feel like I've never seen him
smile as much and as big he cried when
both of our kids were born and he also
shed a tear on our wedding day the pair
welcomed their son in 2011 and their
daughter in 2018. she's only four years
old but I'm a strong believer that yes
I'm a strong believer that children
learn through observation
she's going to learn and see how I
navigate through this world
and so she motivates me to make the
right decisions no matter what those
decisions are whether they're in
relationships whether they're with your
job your career she really does she's an
extension of who I am news of Tia's
split came on the same day as Tamara
released her Memoir and when ET spoke to
Tia she teased that she has some stories
to tell of her own is it your turn to
put out a memoir who you know what I was
thinking about this I think in the next
few years maybe like you have a lot of
stories I do
I do I'm a little mysterious I feel like
I I do have a lot to say it's just when
am I gonna say it
[Music]